[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a hungarian drama film
called white god
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
lily is a 13 year old girl living in
hungary she has a mixed breed dog named
hagen since lily's parents are divorced
she hardly gets along with either of
them the only creature she is close to
is her pet dog at the beginning of the
movie she plays with the dog in a park
while her mother watches them she is
planning to move to the united states
leaving lily to live with her father
daniel permanently daniel works in a
slaughterhouse and hasn't seen lily
since she was three years old he is
surprised that she has brought the dog
with her because his apartment is too
small to hold one he is also not fond of
pets in general but has to compromise
because of his daughter when they get to
the building daniel's landlady tells him
that pets are not allowed in the
apartment he quietly tells her that he
will get rid of it in a few days even
during dinner lily disobeys her father
feeding hagen homemade food they have to
squeeze in the same room because of the
size of the apartment the dog has
separation anxiety and cannot sleep
alone but daniel still locks him in the
bathroom he cries for a long time not
letting anyone sleep at last lily goes
to him and plays franz lists hungarian
rhapsody number two on her trumpet the
dog calms down after listening to the
tune and lily sleeps in the bathtub for
the night a dog and a trumpet the other
people who live in daniel's apartment
building must be pissed the next morning
they are woken up by someone ringing
their doorbell a man from canine control
informs them of a complaint they
received about their dog howling at
night at first daniel tries to hide the
fact that they own a pet but the guy
happens to see hagen in the apartment
daniel is told to pay a large mongrel
fee imposed by the hungarian government
because hagen is a mixed breed he is
strictly against paying money to keep
the dog that he doesn't even want in the
first place that day lily takes hagen to
her music class because her father won't
let him alone in the house since no pets
are allowed in the class either she
hides him inside a cabinet used to store
instruments however when the music
starts to play a scared haggin runs
outside lily's music teacher asks her to
send the dog away and stay in the
classroom but she disobeys him and walks
out the two are walking through the
street when daniel stops them furious at
the fact that he was called by her music
teacher he has decided to get rid of the
dog at any cost he asks lily to give him
to the dog shelter but she stays adamant
about keeping him with her having had
enough of her stubbornness he kicks the
dog out of the car
lily cries and asks the dog to return
but daniel forces her inside and drives
away the poor dog chases them not
wanting to let go of his master but he
cannot keep up with the speeding car
for the next few hours he waits in the
street for lily but she never returns
at home lily wakes up in the middle of
the night and gets ready to go to hagen
but she is found by her father who
forces her back to sleep hagen wakes up
after spending the night under a bridge
he looks around for food and finds a
dead animal by the side of the road
after contemplating whether he should
eat it he decides against it following
that he reaches a butcher shop and looks
at the meat longingly a white stray dog
catches his attention who he follows and
he ends up in the back of a shop several
stray dogs are eating the leftovers but
they bark at hagen when he tries to get
a bite this attracts the butcher who
chases them all away a naive hagen stays
put in his place making the butcher even
more angry he is about to attack the
poor dog with a knife but is distracted
by the white dog at the right time
taking the opportunity both dogs run
away and reach a puddle where all of the
stray dogs of the area have gathered to
drink water however they are soon
approached by workers from animal
control who catch them and put them in
cages hagen and his friend managed to
run away while being followed he is
chased through the streets and
eventually saved by a homeless person
after the workers leave the man
forcefully ties a rope around his neck
and keeps him as a pet in the meantime
daniel takes lily back to her music
class and makes her apologize to the
teacher for yesterday after the class
she secretly goes to the street where
they had left the dog the previous day
she looks for him all around the
neighborhood but to no avail she also
posts posters of the missing dog
everywhere she can
later at night the homeless man sells
hagen to a dealer he is chained with his
kind in the back of a shop the next
morning a client named sabolks comes
looking to buy a dog for dog fighting
competitions the dealer claims haggin
won't be good for fighting because he is
a lap dog but sabolks buys him anyway
hagen is giving a sleeping pill which
makes him pass out following that
sabolks brings him to his house and
gives him a mixture of protein powder to
make him more aggressive sabolks beats
him regularly he is mostly starved and
caged the entire day the only time he is
let out is when sabolks trains him if he
doesn't do as he is told he is beaten
brutally the dog's life has changed for
the worse
sabots's training technique gets tougher
every day hagen is no longer the gentle
dog he used to be he eventually turns
very aggressive ready to be let into the
battlefield in the meantime lily
continues her search for him she goes to
a dog shelter and asks its owner about
him she is told that he might have been
hit by a car or died in a street fight
her day gets worse when her bicycle gets
stolen from outside the shelter
that night haggin is brought to the
fighting ground by his master the rules
of the match are simple for a dog to win
the other one has to die
people bet on them and earn a lot of
money when sablux brings haggan in
everyone assumes that he is going to
lose they even tell sabolks he could
have done better but the guy is
confident about his training the match
between hagen and a rottweiler starts
after a fierce fight both are left
bloodied and injured but at last hagen
gets a tight grip on his opponent and
wins the match
impressed by his skills a dog dealer
approaches sabolks wanting to buy him
when sabokes refuses they get into an
argument amidst it the lights go off and
haggin takes the opportunity to run away
he runs the entire night as far as he
can from the dog dealers
lily on the other hand is running home
after her bicycle was stolen she meets a
friend from her music class named peter
he is about to go to a high school party
which she asks to join at first he is
reluctant about bringing her but he
figures that she can be used to carry
drugs to the party without being caught
he makes her hide some pills in her
pocket which she sneaks into the party
everyone there is way older than her but
lily doesn't care she sits in a corner
and watches everyone dance by the end of
the night she's fallen asleep on the
floor the next morning the party is
raided by the police when lily is found
with drugs she is taken to the police
station thankfully her tests come out
negative so she is allowed to return
home with her father oh so she wasn't
doing the drugs just selling them that's
fine daniel cries for the first time in
years after seeing his daughter well and
alive he had been worried to death the
previous night he apologizes to her for
taking hagen away from her and promises
to buy her a new dog
lily forgives her father and reconciles
with him after which they return home
happily meanwhile haggan reaches the
puddle the next morning and reunites
with his friend the white dog they are
together playing by a river when the
people from animal control take them
away and put them in a shelter
hagen is injured because of the fight
and is treated for it he is put in a
cage with hundreds of other stray dogs
and given food while most of the dogs
devour it he doesn't even look at the
food the following day people come to
the shelter to adopt the dogs of their
choice a girl seems to like hagen but he
barks at her and is aggressive towards
the workers the owner asks for him to be
put down somewhere else lily is playing
the trumpet at a concert with her
orchestra daniel is in the audience to
cheer for his daughter hagen is about to
be thrown in a cage with the other dogs
when he attacks the dog handler he grows
aggressive and bites the man on his neck
killing him eventually the other dogs
follow his lead and rush out of the cage
since hagen is the one to free them they
make him the leader of the pack the
owner of the shelter tries to stop him
but he pushes her aside and escapes with
the others they run through the city and
chaos ensues all around them people run
away to save their lives as the dogs
begin to attack everyone in their way
eventually the dogs also reach the
concert that lily is playing they
surround it from all sides making the
audience barricade themselves within the
auditorium for safety the performance
stops as everyone starts to panic lily
senses that hagen is also with them and
runs outside despite peter warning her
not to a stranger tells lily and peter
to not go downstairs because the entire
city is in lockdown but they do not
listen at last she cycles down the empty
streets trying to find hagen believing
that she can stop the havoc eventually a
pack of dogs chases behind her she falls
to the ground but they ignore her as if
they are on a mission it turns out that
hagen is leading them to all of the
people who have hurt him in the past
first he finds sabbox and approaches him
soon he is joined by his pack who attack
him leaving a bloody mess behind when
lily gets to the location they have
already left a policeman finds her and
puts her in the car however she escapes
and cycles away looking for hagen yet
again she reaches a meat shop and finds
the butcher dead on the floor he was the
same guy who tried to kill hagen earlier
in the movie she calls daniel and asks
him to stay inside at any cost he on the
other hand is worried about her safety
somewhere else the police force shoots
and kills several dogs but more of them
keep on coming the pack goes to the
dealer who had sold hagen in the market
and kills him as well
now their final target is daniel lilly
cycles back to her home and finds the
landlady dead she freaks out and runs to
her apartment finally realizing what
haggan is trying to do
knowing that her father's life is also
in danger she runs back to the
auditorium daniel sees her safe and is
relieved however lily is soon approached
by hagen who appears to have forgotten
her after everything he has been through
as he growls at lily his army joins him
they are about to attack her when daniel
comes forward with a blowtorch to
distract them and save his daughter when
they still do not calm down lily again
plays franz lists hungarian rhapsody
number two on her trumpet hagen finally
remembers her because of the tune he
calms down and the pack follows his lead
they all lay on the ground listening to
her play
daniel is shocked and relieved at the
fact that the trumpet is actually useful
for something he's also relieved that
lily is safe
at last she also lays on the ground with
the dogs the movie ends as daniel joins
them
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching